Speaker 1: Let's go next.
Where are we going next?
Let's go to Alex from New York.
Alex, welcome.
Hi, David.
Hi.
Speaker 3: So I know we're looking ahead at
the 22, 2022 midterms, but I just wanted to
ask about 2024.
So because I know we've gotten mixed signals
about Joe Biden running for reelection.
Yes.
What is the possibility?
Do you think he can beat Trump and do you
think he'll run for reelection?
Speaker 1: Too early to say, and I don't think
he's going to run for reelection.
On whether he could beat Trump.
I mean, is Trump under indictment?
Is Trump still popular with Republicans when
the time comes?
I just think it's an empirical question we
don't have the answer to.
My opinion is that Joe Biden is not going
to run for reelection.
I know that that's controversial among my
audience, but I don't I don't believe Biden
will run for reelection.
Speaker 3: What reasons do you have for that?
Speaker 1: I think he's just not interested
in it.
I think that he was so sort of he's a transitional
president, hopefully out of Trumpism.
I think his age is a factor.
I just don't know that it's something that
is of interest to him.
Although I have to say, with the resurgence
that the but the rebirth that the Biden administration
has had in the last two months, I'm feeling
less confident about that.
But I still think if you give me just like
an even odds bet right now, I say Biden does
not run.
I would be glad to be wrong.
Speaker 3: All right.
Speaker 1: Well, thank you, David.
Thank you.
There's Alex from New York with a very precise
question.
Just a reminder, if you're holding on to chat
with me, if your name in the waiting lobby
is anything other than your name and where
you were calling from, you will not be called
on.
So people who have nicknames listed, people
who are using parentheses to get to the top
of the list, all these different things you
will not be called on.
The only format that is valid is, for example,
Mike from Baco.
Mike is next.
Mike is Baco how it's pronounced?
I've never heard of that.
Speaker 3: It's actually Bakersfield.
Oh, it's just a nickname for Bakersfield.
Speaker 1: I did not know that.
Mike from Bakersfield, welcome.
Speaker 3: Thank you.
Yeah, I'm actually a big fan.
Yeah.
So my question would be, how what is your
favorite?
Speaker 1: Okay.
What is my favorite?
What?
And they're gone.
All right.
Very good, man.
We are we are really struggling with some
of these calls today.
Let's go next to Kevin from San Diego, California.
Since we dropped a call from Bakersfield,
I figure we'll go near nearby.
What's going on there, Kevin?
Speaker 3: You know.
Speaker 5: San Diego is clearly a much superior
place to Bakersfield.
We at least pick up the calls, and I don't
think I'm going to leave anytime soon.
Speaker 1: In my experience, I have to agree
with you, no offense to people from Bakersfield,
but having been to both, I have to say my
preference is San Diego.
But no offense to anybody.
Speaker 5: Well, yeah, I know that.
That's very, very diplomatic.
Take a few days.
Thank you.
I want to go a little bit away from politics
right now.
I wanted to know, do you have a particular
like workout routine or otherwise?
You know where to stay in shape?
Speaker 1: Well, I basically will alternate
cardio and weight training, essentially for
cardio.
I, I like running and biking.
And then in terms of weight training, you
know, I'll find some circuits online.
And then like when I was going to the gym
before the pandemic, I would do them there.
But then, you know, during the pandemic.
Speaker 5: Yeah.
Are you still out of the gym?
Speaker 1: I'm still out of the gym.
But, you know, I'm I'm starting to look at
going back because with my schedule, I'd be
able I just you know, I used to get colds
all the time.
I haven't had a cold in so long.
And I think part of it is spending time at
the gym is a great place to get yourself a
cold, you know?
And I think if I went back, I would be able
to go at a time that it's very, very quiet.
And I think it might be a good thing I do.
There's just so much more equipment, you know?
Speaker 5: Yeah, there is a lot going on at
the gym.
It's it's.
Speaker 3: Worth it for.
Speaker 5: More detail things.
If you're kind of basic on whatever you're
doing like it, you can just lift some weights
or have like a, you know, oh, in terms of
the thing, do you have like a stationary bicycle
or a treadmill or something or do you like
actually run outside?
I run.
Speaker 1: Outside.
I bike outside.
Speaker 5: All right.
Well, that's the way to do it.
Speaker 1: It really is.
It really is.
Speaker 5: That's about it.
Speaker 1: David, should I be taking some
kind of protein powder, do you think?
Or am by probably okay.
Speaker 3: I mean.
Speaker 5: I'm not an expert on any of these
kind of things.
I think it's like basically you can get really
detailed on the things that you're doing with
any kind of fitness stuff.
But if you are at the level where you're not
seeing yourself like improve a lot over what
you're doing regularly, you can always add
something else.
So like protein powder at that point is probably
a good idea, but if you're just kind of if
you're fine where you are, you probably don't
need it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, no, I'm not going to use
any protein powder.
I was just curious.
Your opinion.
Speaker 5: Oh, well, that's fair.
I mean, you did not take my opinion on that.
All right.
Taco place that you said last time.
Speaker 1: The taco place in San Diego.
It was, I believe it's called is it Posto?
Speaker 3: I it was something.
Speaker 5: Like that, but it looked like fancy
and tasty and I wanted to try there and I
couldn't remember exactly what it was and
yeah.
Speaker 1: Oh, no, I believe it.
It's puesto.
Speaker 5: Puesto puesto.
Okay.
Speaker 1: Fantastic.
Taco.
Yeah, the brisket taco is hard to beat.
Speaker 5: If you're ever in San Diego again,
I highly recommend you go to Tacos, El Gordo
and National City.
Okay, that isn't way less fancy of a place,
but the auto body tacos are to die for.
They're amazing.
Speaker 1: Beautiful.
All right.
I appreciate the recommendation.
Speaker 5: All right.
Speaker 1: All right.
Take care.
Very good.
Very, very sub.
It was really, like, meaty calls today